Ich würde vorschlagen,
wir kontrahieren
den musculus orbicularis oris
und führen die zusammen.
Alles klar.
Menschliche Lippen sind ziemlich
auffällig, wenn man sie mit denen
unserer tierischen Freunde
vergleicht.
1. Sind sie nach außen gestülpt und
2. haben wir eine Grenze zwischen
der normalen Haut und der
Lippenhaut, die Vermillion Border
genannt wird.
Vermillion ist englisch für
zinnoberrot und auch, wenn unsere
Lippen nicht strahlend rot sind,
so hebt sich ihre Farbe vom Rest
des Gesichts ab.
So ist es auch kein Zufall, dass wir
uns unsere Lippen gern rot anmalen.
Auch im Tierreich
sind rote Körperteile beliebt,
um potenzielle Partner anzulocken.
Nur weil wir unsere auffälligen
Lippen dazu benutzen, uns zu küssen,
heißt das nicht,
dass uns küssen angeboren ist.
Es gibt Kulturen, die nicht küssen
und die uns für strange halten.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig
verstanden, ihr reibt eure Münder
und Zungen aneinander?
Küssen ist wissenschaftlich
hochinteressant.
Philematologie nennt man
die Wissenschaft des Küssens.
Hey Baby, an dir würde ich gern
philematologische Studien machen.
Doch der Ursprung des Küssens
beschäftigt die Forscher.
Ich stelle euch heute 3 Antworten
vor,auf die Frage, warum küssen wir?
1. Küssen kommt vom Stillen. Manche
sagen, man braucht ca. 40 Muskeln
beim Küssen. Andere sagen, es sind
sogar 140. Kommt auf den Kuss an.
Sagen wir, es sind relativ viele
Muskeln und immerhin verbrennt man
beim Küssen
etwa 3-7 Kalorien pro Kuss.
In der Regel beginnt
ein Kuss mit dem Lippenspitzen.
Dafür wird der Muskel
Orbicularis Oris zusammengezogen.
Derselbe Muskel, mit dem sich Babys
auch an der Mutterbrust festsaugen.
Übrigens, in welche Richtung
dreht ihr euren Kopf beim Küssen?
Die Mehrheit, etwas 2/3, drehen
ihren Kopf beim Küssen nach rechts.
Das könnte daran liegen,
dass 80 % der Mütter ihre Babys an
der linken Brust stillen. Es kann
also sein, dass wir einen Rechtsdreh
schon als Baby verinnerlichen.
2. Küssen kommt vom Füttern. Wenn
man darüber nachdenkt, dann ist
Küssen eigentlich ziemlich eklig.
Man würde auch keinen Speichel
von jemand anderem trinken.
Aber Speichel von Mund zu Mund
auszutauschen, finden wir super.
Noch ekliger ist aber die Theorie,
dass Küssen vom Mund zu Mund-Füttern
stammt. Viele Vögel und Schimpansen
füttern ihre Babys von Mund zu Mund.
Viele Forscher glauben,
dass Küssen eine Erfindung
der Mütter der Urzeit ist, die ihre
zahnlosen Babys das Essen vorkauten,
um es dann über
den gespitzten Mund einzuflössen.
Gab damals kein Babybrei
im Glas oder Pürierstäbe.
3. Küssen kommt vom Riechen.
Wart ihr schon in der Situation,
dass ihr jemanden attraktiv fandet,
aber nach dem 1. Kuss nicht mehr so?
Vielleicht konntet ihr
euch einfach nicht riechen.
Viele Pheromone, das sind
Duft-Botenstoffe, werden an unseren
Nasenflügeln gebildet und abgeson-
dert, so dass es sich lohnen könnte,
die Nasen mal
näher zusammenzustecken.
Es gibt viele interessante Studien
dazu, wie der Geruch eines Menschen
mit seiner Attraktivität
zusammenhängt.
Dazu könnte man mal
ein ganzes Video machen.
Viele Forscher glauben, dass
der Kuss eine Art auschecken ist,
ob jemand als potenzieller Partner
in Frage kommt, in dem man
seinen Speichel kostet
oder seinen Geruch einatmet.
Wenn ihr gerade niemanden zum
Knutschen habt und neidisch auf
knutschende Paare seid, dann denkt
doch einfach an vorgekautes Essen,
dann sieht das schon
weniger spassig aus.
Schön schlau.